Donald Trump recently said that bigotry
and Prejudice are going to leave very
easily and quickly from the United
States
just hours after using a racial slur
himself against a sitting Democratic
senator you probably know that Trump has
a long history of claiming that certain
problems are going to be really easy to
fix you might remember that he said
coronavirus was just going to leave in
April it's gonna wash the Roo and leave
like a miracle obviously that didn't
happen he also said three and a half
years ago that his son-in-law Jared
Kushner was going to very easily and
quickly fix the israeli-palestinian
conflict obviously that has not happened
and here is Donald Trump speaking at a
so-called transition to greatness event
saying it himself bigotry will leave
quickly and easily just hours after he
tweeted the slur pocahontas about
senator Elizabeth Warren here is Donald
Trump himself saying it Americans are
good and virtuous people we have to work
together to confront bigotry and
Prejudice wherever they appear but we'll
make no progress and heal no wounds by
falsely labeling tens of millions of
decent Americans as racist or bigots we
have to get everybody together we have
to be in the same same path I think this
if we don't do that we have we have
problems and we'll do that we'll do it I
think we're going to do it very easily
it'll go quickly and it'll go go very
easily so so it's so part of the
solution to bigotry and racism from
seth's is to stop calling people racist
when they say racist things and then
racism will very quickly leave our
country and remember just hours before
Trump said this he tweeted a slur about
Elizabeth Warren where he said quote
seriously failed presidential candidate
senator Elizabeth Pocahontas Warren just
introduced an amendment on the renaming
of many of our legendary military bases
from which we trained to win two world
wars
hopefully our great Republican senators
won't
all for this also relevant to racism and
bigotry is that Donald Trump was
attacking Elizabeth Warren because she
introduced an amendment looking to
rename American military bases that were
named after pro-slavery Confederate
generals remember the Confederacy was
fighting to preserve states rights for
legal slavery during the American Civil
War this is the same donald trump who
told four american congress women of
color to go back to their countries this
is the same Trump who referred to
African countries as you know what
obviously Donald Trump as we know is in
way over his head and himself is a
heavily bigoted individual but I want to
put you in his shoes for a moment as
gross as that might feel if you don't
have any understanding of bigotry and
racism if you don't understand the
history of bigotry and racism in the
United States as Donald Trump doesn't
understand if you don't understand how
long bigotry and racism have been around
in the United States and how ingrained
in the country they are you might
believe that you could really quickly
and and easily fix bigotry and racism in
reality what's going on is that Donald
Trump completely lacks self-awareness
and is himself a huge part of the
problem in general when Trump is wrong
about something or makes a mistake which
he never admits to of course you can
usually chalk it up to a combination of
him being what we might call a bad
person like he lacks empathy completely
you can chalk it up to him being
ignorant some would call it stupid but
that's a bit of a pejorative ignorant
maybe is better and/or that he's
delusional in other words he lives in a
fantasy world that includes delusions of
grandeur etc in this case Trump saying
bigot free we'll leave quickly and
easily it's a lack of empathy for the
problems with bigotry in our country
combined with ignorance about the
history of bigotry and racism in the
United States with the addition of the
delusion he holds that he can fix any
problem it's sort of like the perfect
trifecta now one last thing I know that
some of you lovely right-wingers are
going to write to me
or leave a comment on YouTube or tweet
me and you're gonna say David Pocahontas
isn't a slur with somebody's name skip
it skip I'm not gonna respond to you
I'll tell you right now Donald Trump is
using it as a slur here - sarcastically
refer to what in her family was an oral
history of Native American ancestry this
is sort of like if you sarcastically or
pejoratively refer to a Jewish person as
slomo when [ __ ] is not their name you
would have these same right-wingers
going damage slo-moes just short for
Solomon it's just a name how is it a
slur the context matters and the context
can make it a slur so please guys right
right wingers put in it is mostly guys
not women don't even bother writing to
me about it okay
in the context Trump used it it was a
slur if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's linked Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video